- [Narrator] From a distance,
this may not look like a village.
But get up close and you'll
see it's a small settlement
built into the heart into
debris of an erupted volcano.
(quiet upbeat music)
Located in the northwest corner of Iran
is the ancient village of Kandovan.
These unusual looking peaks were created
when now dormant volcano
Mount Sahand erupted
thousands of years ago.
Over time, the volcanic
ash, lava, and debris
hardened to stone and the unique shapes
are the result of weathering.
Inside the peaks are livable
caves that have been turned
into homes by the local villagers.
Surprisingly, they are some of
the most economical on earth.
The cave's insulation means no heating
or cooling is required.
There's also a mosque, a
public bath, and a school.
The term Kandovan is derived
from the Persian word
kando meaning beehives.
And fittingly, 600 people call these hives
their humble home.